One of the first Skypes we ever did was to connect my Tanzanian students...
...with my other passion, which is the Covenant Preparatory School in Hartford, Connecticut.
I thought that these kids and my kids here had so much in common...
...that I wanted them to meet each other, not just through letters.
So, we tried Skype and it worked.
And the first time they saw each other was wonderful because...
...my students here in Tanzania thought that all American students looked like me.
And they were like, "Wow, these kids look like us."
"They talk like us."
"They're not as different as we thought."
They're learning both what's different and much more, what's alike.
When I'm home, my heart's here.
Every minute of the day when I wake up, I can do whatever I have to do...
...because then I know what I'm doing is nothing...
....compared to what they're doing for their education.
They're doing all the hard work.
I'm just supporting them.
We're just blessed with where we're born, it's not...
I didn't choose my parents.
I didn't choose to be born in the United States...
...any more than my students chose to be born where they are.
But they all deserve an education, everybody does.